there's now a perfect finishing touch  for your home and bathroom this holiday  season introducing the toilet Santa  toilet Santa fits perfectly over your  existing toilet and installs in seconds  just take a seat and that's Santa here  your Christmas wishes and toilet Santa's  hat features a small hook to hang an air  freshener if you're nice Horsham  mistletoe if you're naughty why make  your children wait for hours in the mall  when Santa's lap can be available at  home anytime  sorry baby hey Santa buckle up at tacos  in a bowling alley and for an additional  $99 get our exclusive mrs. Claus but de  cover make every trip to the bathroom a  journey to the North Pole  so get your toilet Santa today my  fantasy come true that you'll excuse me  Santa need some privacy  the new toilet Santa order yours now  [Music]  [Applause]  you